Nina: Hi, Sal.
So, tell us a little bit about your book
and the journey that you underwent
before you started the Khan Academy,
which led you to writing this book.
Sal:Yeah, well, the book is ...
Well, it's a little bit about that journey
but really how that journey informed
what Khan Academy has now become
and then, how that could inform what maybe
classrooms could become or
what learning could become
and not in just a kind of
pie in the sky kind of way
but I know, this is really happening
and it really feels like
we're at this inflection point
in what's going on in classrooms,.
This whole
adventure for me started somewhat,
actually, very inadvertently (chuckles),
it was 2004, I was working as an
analyst at a hedge fund at the time.
I've just gotten married.
Family from New Orleans is visiting
me in Boston after my wedding
and it turned out, this one
cousin Nadia was having trouble,
12-years-old, I had
trouble believing that.
She's an extremely bright girl.
Nina: (laughs)
And when I asked her about,
actually, her mom who told
me and I asked Nadia about it
and she said, "Oh, yeah. I'm
having trouble with units."
and I said,
"Let me tutor you."
I think she thought I was just bluffing.
So, I said, "No, we're
gonna work this out."
She went back to New Orleans.
Got her on the phone.
We ended up using some
tools on the internet
so that we could see each
other scroll initially
with a mouse and we got these
little pen tablet things
and
long story short, she went
from being a struggling student
to catching up with her class and
then becoming somewhat advanced
Nina: (laughs)
I called her school and I said,
"I really think Nadia needs
"to retake a placement exam."
and they said, "Who are you?"
Nina: (laughs)
but you know, I then started
tutoring her brothers
and fast forward, two years, we got
around, free tutoring was happening.
I was tutoring 10, 15
family, friends, cousins
and it was at that point that a
and the firm, I was working for,
it was a firm but it was
my boss and his dog and me.
We moved to Silicon Valley
and I was telling a friend
about all the stuff I
was doing with my cousins
and he said well, and I was complaining
that it's getting hard to scale.
I still had a day job.
There's all these students around
the country with time zones
and etc., etc. and he
said, "Why don't you make
"some tutorials to come up on YouTube?"
and I thought that was a silly idea.
Nina: (chuckles)
but I gave it a shot and long story short,
that kind of started
getting a ton of traction.
People started looking at it.
[unintelligible] I was also
was working on this little
software tool for my cousins.
So there's this view that,
"Hey, maybe this could be
"an institution to help
people." and so, we set it up,
as a not-for-profit and then in 2009,
I had trouble focusing on my day job.
So, I quit and started doing
Khan Academy full time.
Nina: Also, tell me a little
bit about the Khan Academy.
What is the business model?
Let's start with the big,
hairy audacious goal,
Sal: (laughs)
and then the business model
that you've based it on.
Sal: Yeah, so the ...
Well, maybe I'll go the other way around
because you know
when I was starting all of these and I was
sitting in the middle of Silicon Valley.
I came from a very for-profit-reality.
There are my friends who are
venture capitalists says,
"Hey, Sal. You know we could fund this
"and it could be this double
bottom line business."
or whatever that means and there
was a lot of temptation there
and there's nothing wrong with that
but there was this feeling.
You know, I was getting all
of these emotional reward
from these thank-you letters
that people were sending me
and the sense that, "Hey, I
was making these simple things
"for my cousin and now you know."
At first tens of thousands,
hundreds thousands
and now, million of students
are using it around the world.
I'd like this stuff to be around
in 100 years or in 500 years.
I don't want this collection
of software and content
and this organization.
I don't want it to skew from
this mission of being able
to reach these people and so,
when I look at other organizations
in the universe that are able
to do that last many, many,
hopefully, centuries and
stay true to their missions,
it's a not-for-profit where
there is no ownership.
It's a public charity and so
I said, "Well, I should set
"this up as a not for profit."
Not quite understanding what that is
and I remember when I was doing
that initial paperwork for it,
the IRS asks you, "What's your mission?"
and I kind of thought about it
for maybe three or four minutes
and I said, "Oh, a free world-class
education for anyone, anywhere."
Nina: Why not? (laughs)
Well, you never want something
you could just check, it's done.
It's an aspiration.
And it was a very delusional
aspirational at the time
when I was literally
operating out of the closet
but yeah, and so the business
model is we're not a business,
we're a 501C3 not for profit but
we still have to sustain ourselves
and the way we want to because we always
want the learning side of education
We always want that to
be free because we think
that's what empowers people.
It's primarily foundation and
philanthropist-driven so far
but we do think there are ways
to sustain itself in other ways
whether it's licensing
content or who knows what?
We're trying to explore
that but we're pretty true
to keeping the content free.
Nina: Sure.
How many students are
you serving right now?
How many instructors?
Can you give me a sense as to how large?
Sal: Yeah, and so-
Nina: And what's the typical profile
of someone who comes to your website?
Sal: Yeah.
So, the organization itself are 36 people.
We're still relatively small
but it feels huge for me
because last year, we were 13 and
a year before that, we were one.
(laughs) We've been growing
fast but in this past month,
we've reached 7 million
students, unique students.
We've reached a total
of 16 million unique.
That's the way you measure
unique students on the web,
delivered 180 million lessons, 700
million problems had been done on the site
and it's students all over the world.
It's pretty much every
country in the world.
Someone has used the
Khan Academy in some way.
20,000 teachers, as far as we can
tell from our data are using it
in their classes or with their
cohorts in some type of ways.
It's kind of crazy, I call it,
it's surreal for where it came from.
Nina: Yeah, let's talk a little bit about
how a classroom or a school can use you
with this concept of a flipped classroom.
Explain that to our viewers.
Sal: Yeah, and I'll do two things because
as flipped classroom has somewhat
been tied to Khan Academy
and it is an interesting idea
and it is I think a forward step
but part of the whole point
of this whole book was
to tell people that we're not
necessarily about this flip.
We're actually about pushing the
envelope even further than the flip.
In a flip model, right now, at
home you do problems traditionally.
That's called homework
and then the classroom.
A lot of time in a traditional classroom,
we spent lectures and the
flip is in a [pre-date]
Khan Academy early on at
these videos out there.
Some teachers were telling me,
"Hey, you made a decent video
"on meiosis or on you
know, projectile motion.
"I don't have to give
that lecture anymore.
"My students have been watching
it on their time and pace.
"They can remediate without
taking up class time
"and then when they go to class,
" that's when they can either
ask me questions, clarifications
"and we can do problems together."
So, what used to be homework, the
problem sets could now be done
inside the classroom.
And the advantage there is,
the real learning occurs
when you do the engagement, when
you're doing the problem sets
and I think traditionally,
students either don't do homework
or have trouble doing homework
because there's no one
at home to help them out.
Now, they're in the classroom.
They have the teacher.
They have their peers, which
is an underutilized resource
in the classroom.
Not only to help you but
when you help others,
you learn a lot better.
And it also gives the teacher
lens on how the class is doing.
When you're lecturing, it's very
hard to know where people are.
I mean you might be able to
pull them, ask a few questions
but it's very hard.
A lot of times, the students
are a little bit, blank faces
but now, if you're doing
problem solving together,
you can do much more,
you can understand where
students are and diagnose them
and so that's the flip.
What used to be homework in the classroom,
what used to be
lectures, are now at home.
Makes the classroom interactive,
students can get lectures
at their time and pace.
Great.
What I focus on a lot in the book is,
let's go even further
because still, even the flip,
assumes that all the students are
going to cover the same material
at the same pace together
and what I talk a lot about,
is this
we've all been indoctrinated in the system
and when I talk about the
system, I'm not talking about
what should be the student/teacher ration
or what charter or private or public.
I'm talking about the system.
I'm talking about grouping
kids by age-based cohorts.
They cover certain subjects in a set pace.
We grade them based on
their variable understanding
and then we keep pushing them forward
and we just assume that's what school is
but what I go through
great lengths to show is,
no, this is actually
relatively new phenomena.
It's about 200 years.
I mean, it's not that new.
So, 200 years old that we inherited
from a country that no longer exists.
Nina: The Prussians (chuckles).
and even to us, I guess, it was
during the Industrial
Revolution, was the first time
that people seriously thought about,
"How can we educate everybody?"
Before that, it was, you're the
son of a lord and you would get a,
king and you get a private tutor and
the private tutor was a [goal] standard.
They're working at your pace
and differentiating it for you
but now, all of a sudden in
Prussia, there's like, "Okay,
"we wanna have mass
education. How do we do it
"in a practical way?" and whoa,
it's the Industrial Revolution.
Well, how do we do anything
in a practical way?
We stick them on an assembly
line and as they go through,
we do something to the
product and then hopefully
at the end, we have a decent product.
And so, they essentially applied
the same model to classrooms.
The kids are in these
brackets based on age.
You know, it's funny.
I was talking to a friend
and her child already knows
how to read and everything and
she was trying to get the child
into the kindergarten.
He's like born in October or something and
and the school said, "Oh yeah
"he's a very bright kid
but you know, we can't.
"He's too small."
and I told my frie-
and she came back, she's
like, "Yeah, he's too small."
I was like, "Look, if that's
what they were concerned about,
"they should be grouping them by size."
That's (laughs) the obvious
natural, but so that's the model.
And even the flip is in
the context of that model.
On week three, we cover parabolas.
Week four, we cover systems of
equations and even if you have,
we give students grades.
We give them a B and that B shows that
they have a gap in their knowledge,
A C, even a D, you can get an exam
but then you move to the next topic.
That's usually building on top of that,
which is pretty much
dooming you to failure.
Nina: Exactly.
Sal: And so, what, I advocate strongly
and we're already seeing this
in schools, trying to experiment
or moving this direction is, if you
take lecture out of the classroom,
there's no longer the need for everyone
to move together at the same pace.
And as soon as you get
rid of that assumption,
you can completely rethink
what a classroom can be.
You can start having everyone
run at their own pace,
you can leverage class time
when humans are together
for actual interactivity.
You can start saying, "Well,
why do we only have one teacher
"in the room? Why can't we
have two teachers in the room?
"Why do we have a bell ring?"
and this bell ringing,
this is like a factory,
in a 19th century factory.
Why do we have a bell ringing that's
saying, "Stop what you're doing
"on chemistry. You must
now start English."
and we all know.
Anyone who's done
anything creative because
that's the best way to stop creativity,
Nina: You're done.
Nina: Move on.
And so, what
what we've advocating is move to reality
with possibly the help of
tools like Khan Academy
so that every student can
run at their own pace.
Soon teachers have dashboards,
tools that empower them
and that use class time for
interactivity and creativity.
Nina: Right, right.
You touched on this a little
bit but explain a little bit
about why is it that your
platform has taken off
and is getting so much attention, when
so many others were kind of trying
to do the same thing
on the for-profit side,
some on the non-profit
side haven't succeeded.
Sal: Yeah, it's an open question.
It's a question which we're
constantly asking ourselves
because we know whatever
the secret sauce is,
we don't wanna lose it
somewhere in the process.
My best guess of why there's
this initial way of traction
from 2006 to 2007, even
it continuous to grow is,
those first videos I
think it was fortunate
that it was just some guy
making it for his cousins.
Nina: They were easy to use.
Nina: Or understand.
They felt very human.
And I think the big learning
is, is that people were hungry,
I wasn't the first person
to make videos on YouTube.
to think of teaching,
as soon as radio came out, people
were saying, "Oh, we'll use this
"to teach the world." and
then TV, "Oh, we'll use this
"to teach the world." and VCR.
Now, it's on demand.
But historically, it was
either a videotape of someone
at a chalkboard, traditional
class, which feels very,
it feels distant even when
you're in the classroom.
You're there, I'm over here,
the next step in the equation
and you do it like that.
So, that's very, not very [unintelligible]
and we make that into video.
It's even harder to see,
"What are they writing there?
And I can't hear them."
and these felt very personal.
You're sitting next to me.
I think the other dimension of
it is just a conversational tone.
I think a lot of people, they
try to make it very polished,
which is not bad but in that
process, you lose the humanity.
So, it sounds like your
GPS system you know,
"The next step with this
equation is when ... "
and I think hopefully, this
is something that I try
to put into it is,
one of the things I
think allowed me to do,
to kind of thrive in math or
science and then eventually,
even finance was, I felt like I had a
really holistic understanding of things
and my basics were really,
really, really solid
and then my basics in
algebra were really good.
So, when I went into
calculus, I was like, "Oh
"this is intuitive." and when
I went to corporate finance,
I was like, "This is intuitive.
There's nothing new here."
and you see all the really,
really smart people,
they're just learning for the next exam,
memorizing formulas then they
forget it and then when they see
a related concept, it's
like, "What's this?"
And so, what I tried in those
early days for my cousins is,
give a sense of intuition, draw
the connections between things
so that when they see this new concept,
it's not some random new concept.
It's connected to everything
they learned before
and I get a lot of letters
and I would have assumed that
that only been appealing to
the motivated kids so to speak
but I get a lot of letters from
kids that were traditionally,
disengaged or demotivated
and they said, "That's why
"I was demotivated. No one
was explaining the why.
"No one was giving me the connections."
So, hopefully, that's why people
have been, I guess connecting
to the content.
Nina: Yeah, so let's talk a
little bit about virtual education
and offering the types of
things that you're offering.
A lot of people are still a
little wary of these reforms.
They see it as a mechanism to
ultimately get rid of teachers
in the classroom or reduce class sizes.
You talked a little bit
about this in the book
and explain that a little bit.
Sal: Yeah, yeah.
No, I think that's a super important point
because whenever, when we've
learned the last 15, 20 years
Nina: They think about robot replacement.
It's like, "Is that going
to replace the physically?
The Barnes & Noble versus Amazon.com,
there's a natural contention there.
That's
exact opposite of the way I think
is going to happen in education.
Everything we do is not going
to replace a physical school.
I have young kids.
I want them to go to a physical school.
I want them to get interaction.
What it will do, is I think, give
all of our children the experience
that I think every parent and every
teacher or every student wants
to be a part of, and then even now,
we're going to physical experience
but we're not leveraging the humans.
We're going but for the most part,
people are sitting passively there
and they're listening.
It's hard for the teachers too
because it's hard to just speak
for 60 minutes without getting
that connection with the students
and so, what we're
advocating is leverage tools,
so you can get maybe information
delivery out of the way.
So you can get some of the
problem solving out of the way
but so when people go
and they have class time,
the scariest class time
with other human beings that
that's optimally interactive and
not interactive in the web sense,
interactive in the human sense.
Class time is all conversation.
Class time is all peer tutoring
and working with their teacher.
Class time is all doing
open ended projects and so,
I talk about this in the book
and I gave a Ted Talk a bunch,
the irony here is I strongly believe
and it's not just talk again,
we're seeing this in classrooms,
is that
you can actually use technology
to make the classroom more human
and I'm very careful.
You mentioned there's skepticism.
I think there should be.
I'm skeptical when someone says,
"Hey, we just ordered
500 iPad for our school."
and I say, "Well, what
are you gonna do with it?"
or, "How are you gonna integrate
it into the curriculum?"
or, "How are you gonna leverage
it to fundamentally transform
"what's going on?" and
there usually aren't a lot
of answers there, and so, I
think it is good to be skeptical
but at the same time, there
is, I think a reason for hope.
Nina: How do you evaluate
the impact of your courses?
Since again, you talked a little
bit about grades in your book
and how you don't like
the concept of grading.
How do you know that they
have actually worked?
Sal: Yeah, and I'll tell you.
I mean a lot of times, when I
grew up, I remember sometimes
we meet people who said, 'I
don't believe in grades.'
and I thought they were these kind of
like granola-bar hippie-type people
that you know, and now, I think I
appreciate what they were saying.
Grades, normally when you say
people who don't like grades,
you really think, they're
being touchy-feely.
They're not being rigorous
but actually, they're saying
grades aren't rigorous enough.
Grades are this thing that
give this feeling of rigor.
Oh, A, B, A is , "Oh, you
really know your stuff."
F, "You don't know your stuff."
One, they're somewhat
arbitrary, depends on the test,
depends on how it's measured.
But even more than that,
when you give grades,
especially, in the sense,
if you got a C on an exam,
you have obvious weaknesses,
assuming that it was even a good exam.
You have obvious weaknesses.
That should be used as an
assessment to say, "Okay,
"you need to now improve
on those weaknesses,
"before we move onto a more advance
topic." like it's common sense.
Get your basics down but instead,
we use grades as a value judgment.
"You're smart. You're dumb.
You're fast. You're slow."
and that's just going to be
a self-fulfilling prophecy.
So, what we say is, "No, let's just make
sure everyone masters every concept."
So rather than having superficial
understanding of algebra
and then moving onto trigonometry,
make sure you really understand
algebra deeply and then trigonometry's
gonna make a lot more sense.
It's gonna be a lot easier to learn
and if you master trigonometry
then calculus is going to
start seeming very intuitive.
In terms of how we're doing
it, we're working with schools,
and famously, Los Altos, which
is now using Khan Academy.
It's probably one of the best,
if not the best school district
in the country is using Khan
Academy for 5th through 8th grade
as one of the tools that they use .
and there we have formal studies going on
to understand exactly, how this is
impacting students and teachers,
both objectively on things
like test scores and grades
but also on things
subjectively, "Are the teachers
more excited about their work?
"Are the students more
excited about their work?"
And then on top of that, we have
3 million problems down a day
on our site.
We have this huge number of students,
7 million a month using our site.
We have this treasure trove
of data on our site itself.
Nina: Monitoring it on a daily basis.
Yeah, I mean all these other
web companies are able to do.
We as a kind of education
not-for-profit can now do,
using analytics,
optimizing for engagements,
seeing what kind of learning is going on.
Nina: Great, great.
So, tell me a little bit
about, you gave a great
historical overview of how we
came to educate students today,
the way we're educating them.
Did you always hold these
views and know this information
before you stumbled on the
Khan Academy or this platform
that you created?
Or were these things that
you studied afterwards?
Sal: (laughs)
Sal: It's been very serendipitous.
Sal: You know, it's been a combination.
I actually think it's more of the latter.
Obviously, all of us has spent
a lot of time in the system.
I think the whole time,
anybody who knew me growing up,
I mean, they knew that I was always like,
Nina: Questioning, right.
"Why can't I tutor?"
I used to get reprimanded
for trying to tutor my-
This is sort of been a
really positive interaction
and so, this question, you go
to college and you're like,
"People are sitting in this lecture hall,
"is anything really happening in here?"
It seems like all the learning is
happening under the cram session,
three days before the final
and so, there is always
these ideas and then obviously,
when I started working
with my cousins, I started seeing the ...
my cousins were motivated.
They were, for the most
part, good students
but they were having these
huge gaps in their knowledge.
Nina: It's called Swiss-cheese learning.
Swiss cheese learning (chuckles)
etc., and so, and very pragmatically,
I started building these tools
and it's really a process
of discovery.
Teachers e-mailing me, saying,
"Hey, we're using it this way.
"We're using it that way."
and so it's a combination of
these instincts of like,
"Well, how did I learn?
"How do other people I know,
who learn things holistically,
"how did they learn? What
am I seeing with my cousins?
"What are teachers telling me?"
and then it's kind of getting more
and more traction.
I started having people tell
me about a lot of this stuff.
I mean, I knew a little bit
about the history before.
I've heard about this whole
committee of 10 in 1890,
somebody told me about
that in high school.
But it was interesting
that even the research,
the reasons why I made
the video so short is
because YouTube limited
me to 10 minutes but then
I used to have researchers
telling me, "No, there's actually
"cognitive research that shows
..." and that's where a lot
of that research from the book come from.
Actually people, especially dance
academic content can't pay attention
for more than 10 to 15 minutes.
So, it starts as, "Wow,
so why are we doing this?
"Why are we using class time,
this time with human beings
"for these hour-long lectures,
sometimes 90-minute lectures,
"can't we get people to interact more?"
And the more I did
research, a lot of these
kind of just basic common sense
ideas [gelled] with research
and that's when you feel best about it
because they are common, every,
it's weird when research tells
you something very non-intuitive,
but here it's telling you something
very, very, very intuitive
and the only hard to grasp thing
is that we're indoctrinated
into a strange model.
Nina: Right, right.
It all make sense.
Tell me a little bit
about your own education.
I mean something despite
the regiment of the system
that you grew up in, something
must have gone right.
Was it a teacher?
Was it your parents you think
who kind of built this sense
of inquisitiveness or was it, yeah,
did you go to a particular
type of school that was open
to nurturing you as an individual
and paying attention
to your specific needs?
Or yeah, did none of
these things work and-
Sal: Yeah, no, no, no.
I mean I,
Nina: (laughs)
if I go and say that none
of that stuff played in.
I mean I think there's probably
a bunch of different factors
and I'm probably forgetting some of them.
One, I was blessed to have an older sister
who was a very good student,
so I think that projected,
when I would walk into a classroom,
the teachers would remember
my sister and say, "Oh, you're
"Farrah's sis- you're Farrah's
brother, you must be."
and I was like in speech
therapy and stuff when I was,
they would project that and
there's actually now studies
that show that that projection
has huge implications
for your own self-esteem.
That was luck.
On top of that, I went to just a,
I would say it was a public
school in Jefferson Parish,
public schools in Jefferson Parish
right outside of New Orleans.
I would say it was the average
American public schools.
All of them, elementary,
middle and high school
but there were some
incredible teachers there.
I think in high school in particular,
Mr. Hernandez, Miss Kennedy,
Miss Kennedy was a journalism
teacher and actually, I would say
that's where a lot of the ideas that
look, class should not be a lecture,
class should be working
alongside the teacher.
It was journalism class, so we
had a product, a creative product
and newspaper to work on.
I was the art editor and
she would give us feedback
and she was like our senior peer
and I remember those interactions
and a lot of the experience
that I got from journalism.
I still think about it when
I'm working on Khan Academy.
I think early in my schooling,
I think this was key and also lucky,
I got into you know, I don't
know what they call it now,
these GT programs and what they did is,
you have this very structured Prussian
curriculum for most of the day,
but then one day, a week, they take
you out of a different classroom
and they take you to these GT classrooms
and there, you're going to this
classroom, which is essentially,
the kind of classroom that
ideally, everyone should have.
It was actually Miss
[Roselle] and Miss [Crouse].
These two teachers and
they had PhDs in education
and I remember the first day walking to GT
and Miss [Roselle] says,
"What do you wanna do?"
and I was like eight and I was like
"I like to draw." and then
she says, "Well, you should
"draw more then." and then she
introduced me to these things,
different styles, different tools to draw,
"What else are you interested
in?" and I was like,
"I like puzzles." and she's like,
"Well, here's some puzzles."
She would give me these brainteasers
and so she was mentoring me
and it was self-pace and I
was able to go to my own pace
and there was other kids
working on interesting things
and I would get inspired by them.
Sometimes, we would work on things
and I think we needed that
breathing room to have re-
I wonder if I didn't have that
experience early on in my life,
whether I would have had the
ability to kind of self-direct
or the ability to say, "Oh,
let me solve that problem."
No one you know, that's an
interesting thing to tackle.
Nina: Right.
So along those lines, do you have
any advice for parents out there
1st grader, 2nd graders
and I'm asking you this
because in your book, you also
highlight how a lot of students
in Southeast Asia, go to
school in order to show off
what they know, not
necessarily to learn in school.
Are there habits that you
think parents can start
to put in place early on, despite how
the schools are approaching education?
Sal: Yeah, and take everything
I say with a grain of salt.
I have a three-year-old
and a one-year-old,
Nina: (laughs)
of seven or eight-year-olds (laughs).
I'm proud to get my one-year-old
off of the pacifier (laughs).
Nina: Well, now that you
know, iPads are very popular.
Sal: You're absolutely right.
Sal: I mean my sense, having
kind of gone through the system
and even we're observing, we're
working with a lot of teachers,
we're working with a lot of schools now,
I would say there's a
couple of dimensions here.
I think it is true.
Asians whether it's East
Asian or South Asian,
there is a culture of school
is where you go to show
what you've already learned at home.
I think that gives those
students an advantage of having
this kind of buffer of their
learning stuff maybe ahead
and I'm not saying that
necessarily has to be the way
but it is a way to
ensure that your student
in the Prussian model, doesn't get,
falls behind and as soon
as they fall behind,
all of these negative
self-perception things
and they start to reinforce each other.
I would do, I mean I'll
tell you what I would do
with my own children.
I would do some combination of
engaging them with a lot of the content
in a way before it becomes stressful
When I was teaching Nadia, algebra
when she was in algebra class,
it was stressful for her
because she's like, "I need to catch up.
"I have an exam on it."
When I started teaching
algebra to her younger brother
who's in 5th grade, he thought it was fun
because there's no stress here.
It was just a fun thing
his cousin was teaching.
At least expose your kids
to the ideas in algebra
and physics and biology
and chemistry early on
so that when they see it in school,
they've already had some exposure.
The other thing I would say
is, "Don't overschedule them."
I mean, I think sometimes the
same parents that would, you know,
the same parents that would
do the teaching ahead of time,
the same time, will also,
"You have piano lessons.
"You have soccer lessons.
You have everything."
and I think there's a
value there definitely
but if it's complete overscheduling,
you have the loss of time for the
child to develop their own creativity
kind of what I had in that GT class.
Frankly, in the ['80s],
I was a latchkey child
where my mom, she worked these odd jobs
and would come along at 6 or 7:00.
And so, me and my sister
would just hang out,
some of it was wasted watching TV
but a lot of it was just this like,
"I wanna build something or I wanna draw."
We would make up games and stuff like that
and kids need that.
They need that free space and
maybe if they're blowing it all
on video games or watching TV,
you need to push them a little bit
or do something creative with them
but they need that time for creativity
and the last thing I would recommend
is that the parents themselves,
engage in learning because
you set that example.
If you're 40 or 50 years
old and you're going back
in learning algebra or
cosmology or English lit,
it's a sure signal for students.
Nina: Let's talk about your
vision for the ideal classroom
or this futuristic vision
that you outlined here about
what the school of
tomorrow should look like,
which is a lifelong learning
approach to education.
I mean, you also talked about the
college of tomorrow to look like.
I was fascinated by this but
let's talk just about schooling,
your notions of class size
as the ideal classroom,
could potentially have
a hundred students in it
with four instructors roaming
around and helping students.
We talked a little bit
about grades already
but testing, this is one of
those topics that comes up a lot
here in Washington and then with
the discussions on Capitol Hill
but yeah, how would you
describe that vision for us?
Sal: (laughs)
which is not gonna be popular but
yeah, let's delve into this a bit.
Sal: Yeah, I know there's a lot there.
I mean the first to mention is
once you remove lecture from class time,
you say class time is
time for interaction.
You can have students
working at their own pace,
allows you to rethink everything and
so, a lot of the concepts of this book
and a lot of these are happening.
I mean there's schools
that we're working with,
that are doing these things.
They are experiments for their experiments
that all the research and all of the
intuition point in that direction.
Teaching is for the most
part, a solitary profession.
Nina: It's lonely profession.
It's lonely, it's lonely.
And so, you can have a hundred students,
you're not chaining the
student/teacher ration.
You might even improve it.
but you now have four
teachers in the same room.
Now, if one of them gets sick, students
don't have a substitute teacher.
Different students are gonna
connect with different teachers.
They can mentor each other.
They can do group things
with the teachers together
but there's a whole
dimension that you can add.
You could have a physics
teacher, a math teacher,
a chemistry teacher and a biology
teacher, all teaching simultaneously.
Students understand
that all these sciences
and these math actually blend together.
They're not these siloed subjects.
They get a holistic understanding.
The test themselves, you
need some aspect of testing
but you should be very
skeptical of testing
because all test measure what they test
and there's many more [process]
to a human being than that
and so, the dimensions that
there could be some testing
to make sure that students
are getting core competency
and some core skills but
the more important skills,
which I think are completely
unmeasured right now are creativity
and you could never get
someone a creativity score
but you can have someone generate
a portfolio of creative works.
As an employer, we're hiring engineers and
when we get these people
great GPAs from top schools
in the country and they say,
"What have you created?"
That's what engineer is,
building new things
and they haven't created anything
because they've been on the
treadmill the whole time,
just trying to finish problem sets
and they're very, very smart people.
And so, the ideal is that students
over their careers can show
what they've created.
It's not like they write
a paper that gets graded
and gets thrown away.
They write a paper, maybe gets graded
and then they keep working on the paper.
They keep developing it.
When they're 18, they have a novel done.
They have a bunch of papers on policy done
that they can show
people, "This is my work."
They have computer programs written.
They build robots and on top of that,
and this is another dimension,
that's completely missed
in the Prussian model so to speak is,
as
I think in any field, the people
you wanna work with the most,
are the people who have deep
subject matter expertise
but are also always willing to help others
and they have that
communication and that ability
to empathize and
in our current system, we make
everyone very focused on themselves,
"What are your grades? Are
you going to pass the test?
"Cram for the next
exam." and then the model
that we're describing, we're
starting to see in a lot of schools,
let's focus everyone on each other.
So yeah, you go it your own pace,
you might be racing
ahead and that's great.
You're stimulated, you're engaged
but you also have a chance to
reengage with some students
who might be having difficulty
and there's two things,
one, you're gonna be helping that student
but even better, when you
explain that, hopefully,
and you develop your ability to explain,
you'll learn the material better
and you'll learn to communicate.
You'll learn to empathize and
that actually is measurable.
I mean you can have
students rate each other.
You can have people write
assessments for each other.
"Oh, you know, he understood the
stuff but he was a little bit,
"you know, he spoke a little
fast." and you could develop
that aspect.
I'd imagine the transcript of
the future and I say the future
when I mean the future
is like actually now.
Yeah, you would have your test scores.
Your test scores would actually
show actual competency.
It wouldn't be grades.
It would be like, "Yeah, I understand
algebra and I've renewed it.
"I've renewed that I know
algebra well. I know cosmology.
"I'm a writer and here's my writings."
You have a portfolio of your
creative works in multidimensions
and you have reviews from people
that you've helped saying,
"Great person to work with. Really
understood the subject matter.
"Really was able to communicate
well." and those are things
that I think anyone would
actually care about more
than just test scores.
Nina: Right but let's talk a
little bit about what happens
in this classroom or
school in terms of subject.
So, you believe that, so right
now, you have to take math,
you have to take English
language, arts, you start science
at a certain point in time.
I mean do you believe that all
these basics should also be taught
in the school and at what point,
I mean another question
I wanted to ask is,
do you believe that all children can learn
unless they have a serious disability?
Can they all progress to the
levels that you have progressed to
if they simply learn and master
and show an interest really
in the subject matter
that they're studying?
And specifically,
vis-a-vis the STEM fields,
which is science technology,
engineering and math,
which are areas that kids
tend not to get interested in.
Is it just because they
haven't mastered it well
and been pushed to understand it early on
or are there limitations
perhaps in how we are currently,
trying to get the students
to learn these subjects?
Sal: Yeah, so on the latter question,
if you asked me 20 years ago,
I'd have said, "Yeah, maybe
certain people are pre-exposed
"to math and science and
other people aren't."
and that made me feel good
because I was one of the people
who were pre-exposed.
It made me feel like I was meant to be.
There wasn't luck but my
experience with my cousins,
Nadia in particular, but other cousins
and then what we're seeing in schools.
The schools that are
kind of transitioning to
this type of a model where all the
students are learning at their own pace,
building their foundations, we're seeing
day five, yeah, some
kids have raced ahead.
Those are the gifted kids and
some kids are falling behind
like maybe they need to be
remediated and a traditional,
how you would separate them and
you would actually tell these kids,
"You're smart."
You tell these kids either
explicitly or implicitly,
"Hmm, you're not as smart."
but what we're saying is
if you keep them together,
but you allow them
to work at their own pace
so that they're engaged,
they have mentorship from
each other and the teacher,
many times, it's actually
quite hard to predict.
We're trying to predict, it's very hard.
Some of these students were falling
behind, maybe some in algebra class
and some of them didn't
know multiplication well.
Some of them didn't know
how to add fractions.
You give them that opportunity
to really build that foundation
on negative numbers, multiplication,
exponents, whatever it might be
and then these kids race ahead.
Their problem wasn't that they
have some cognitive inability
to understand algebra, the
problem was that they're sitting
in algebra class and for some
reason, they didn't understand
how to multiply or they didn't
understand how to add fractions.
They're just gonna feel
silly in an algebra class
and you'll disengage really just
to predict your own self-esteem.
I'm actually now more
and more convinced that
pretty much everyone,
barring certain exceptions,
we don't know where.
I mean, we're still learning.
We don't know but
progress far ahead and we're
even seeing these classrooms.
We traditionally think motivated kids,
maybe that's 20% of kids but
as soon as you allow people
to engage and fill in gaps
without feeling embarrassed,
they start seeing it's not 20%,
it's 80 or 90% of kids,
can start to feel engaged.
In terms of the first question
about like what subjects and how,
I think it is an interesting and
I talked a little bit about it
as, the subjects that are taught
now are somewhat arbitrary.
They were decided in 1892
by the Committee of 10
mainly university, the
male university presidents
who did not know about, you know this
was before the Federal Reseve existed,
the Interstate Highway
existed, knowledge of DNA
and a bunch of other stuff.
And they decided that at age
14, you should learn algebra,
at age 15, you should learn geometry,
at age 16, you should learn
trigonometry and so on.
You should learn physics, your
senior year in high school.
You should learn, I mean
that's when it was decided
and it hasn't changed since.
I love all of those subjects.
I think they're all fascinating
but I think there are all these questions.
Should there be more statistics?
Statistics more valuable than calculus
or at least as valuable.
Should there be some
knowledge of economics?
Who knows what it will be?
I mean, it's for the society to decide
but the general idea is
at minimum, it should be rethought
within the last 120 years.
There is grounds, the world has changed.
We should think more about
what these subjects are.
And even more, I think
and you alluded to this,
should they even be divvied
up in these siloed subjects?
These siloed subjects, these are,
we're indoctrinated into
it, so it's hard for us
to break our minds from it.
This is the factory model.
You're at this machine in the factory
and so this is what will
be poured into the product.
Okay, now you're gonna have
the paint applied to you.
So now, you're gonna have
the chemistry applied to you.
Now, you move on.
And for some people that
might chip a little bit,
that's fine.
That'll be a cheaper product at the end
but the reality is this,
I mean chemistry is halfway
in between physics and biology
and physics is halfway in between
chemistry and pure mathematics
and all of them actually, have
an aspect of philosophy to them.
All of them have an aspect
of aesthetics to them
and whatever else and
riding can be critical
and logical thinking
is across all program,
you can have something like logic,
which is across everything.
And so, I think the
reality we're moving to is
yes, you won't show competency in things.
So, yeah I understand this domain well.
So, you can go take an exam
and then renew that exam
to show that, "Yes, I still
understand that topic."
but while you're in school,
some might be preparation
for that particular compentency
but most of the time,
will be blending it
where you're not working
to pass an assessment.
You're working to create things
and so, in the process of creating things,
whether it might be a
novel or robot or business,
you're integrating all of these things.
I mean anyone who started a business,
if it's like a tech
business, there's a comp,
there's art design, there's technology,
there's quantitative
thinking and there's writing
and there's just human skills
and you need to integrate it.
That's what actually
matters in the real world.
When you break yourself from
this assembly line model,
you give yourself the
freedom for people to pursue
these types of things.
Nina: Why not create a
Khan Academy Charter School
or even a Khan Academy Private School?
Sal: Yes, it's-
Sal: Yes, no.
Sal: I mean we go back and
forth on that but I am,
we're thinking about it.
We're thinking about it.
Nina: Where would you put it?
Nina: Which country would you pick to ...
Sal: Well, for selfish reasons,
I would probably put it
in Mountain View, California, (laughs)
which would be walking distance
from, no but seriously,
I think it's interesting
because, and this shows
the emphasis we put.
I think a physical experience is
incredibly, incredibly important.
A lot of people in Silicon Valley
say, "What? You're at scale already.
"You're reaching 7 million, you're
growing, you're doubling every year.
"You could reach 100 million
students in five years,
"maybe a billion in your,
"and why are you even
thinking about the physical,"
or, "Why are you thinking
about physical schools?"
and I always say, "Well, that's
because that's the core."
And I also think you need, you
might say, "Well, why focus
"on one school that might be
able to reach a few hundred kids
"when you're able to reach
hundred million maybe one day?"
and the idea is if you
can show examples of this
and there are schools that have
already moved in that direction.
Los Altos moved in that direction.
Summit Prep, which is a charter school,
they've broken down walls.
They have multiple
teachers teaching classes
in these kind of epic environments.
If you show examples of
this, then I think that
that's what moves the dial forward.
Nina: So, how much would be the tuition?
Sal: The tuition would be you know-
Nina: The new school in
New York, 40,000 a child.
Sal: Well, you know that's
an interesting thing pe-
Nina: And it was built without this book
and the vision that [unintelligible]
Sal: Well, no.
Sal: The money is fascinating.
Education is ...
Someone asked me recently is,
"Can you ever spend too much
"on education?" and to some
degree, the answer is no.
I mean it's such an important thing
but at the same time, if you're
going to spend that much money,
you have to think seriously
about how you're spending it.
I've met with some
officials about this and
at public level, charter or
private schools and I just,
regardless of the school, I
say, "How much do you spend
"per pupil per year?"
You ask a private school, some of
them 25,000, 30,000, 40,000 a year.
You ask a public school,
some states, it's low.
It goes down to $5-6,000
a year but most states,
especially, on the east
coast, it's 10, 15,000.
New York City public
school is 18,000 a year.
Cambridge Massachusetts,
$25,000 per year per student
and I say, "Okay, and what's
your average class size?"
And they'll usually say, "Some
number between 20 and 30."
I said, "Okay, private school,
you're charging 30,000 a year,
"There's 20 students. That's
$600,000 per classroom."
That's essentially for the te-
What's directly impacting the students?
The teacher, the classrooms
and maybe the textbook.
Nina: That's it.
Sal: All, I can figure out
is maybe there's 100,000,
150,000 being spent there.
Where is other quarter
of a million or $300,000?
Same thing at any level.
Why can't we instead use, we can low-
The private school, I
think for 10,000 a year,
instead of 40,000, 10,000 a
year, you have 20 students
or let's say you have 30
students in the class,
that's $300,000 a year.
I say pay the teacher 150,000.
Make teaching, you know a lot
of people pay lip service,
"Oh, we should you know,
teaching should be on par
"with the doctors and
engineers and lawyers."
I said, "Well, that's a nice lip
service but if you really believe that,
"pay teachers the same as
doctors, engineers and lawyers."
That's the best signal to society
that you're actually valued
but the money is clearly there
and then it will have to
get cut from all the stuff
that's not impacting the students.
All of the, I don't know.
Every time I ask this to people, I just
do this back of the envelope calculation.
I mean this is what I used
to do in my old career.
I used to speak to CFOs.
I say, "Oh, you're making
this much, what am I missing?"
and the same exact question.
15,000 a year times 30
students is $450,000 a year.
The fully loaded cost of the teacher is
less than half of that plus to see,
where is that money going?
And so, I think you could
do a very good model
for what public schools are spending.
Definitely, some of the more,
the systems are spending
$10,000 plus.
Nina: So, talk a little bit about
how Bill Gates came to discover you
and I just thought that
chapter was so interesting
and yeah, I mean what was it
like to find out all of a sudden
that Bill Gates was watching your videos
and what went through your mind?
Sal: I still wake up in the
morning sometimes wondering
whether that was all made up or a dream.
The site have already gotten traction
but the summer of 2010,
our first donors and/or
started sending me text messages
that Bill Gates was at
the Aspen Ideas Festival,
telling the whole audience
that he uses a site
that he thinks is great
called The Khan Academy
and he uses it with his
kids and he uses it himself,
which made me a little nervous
because those were just for Nadia
but then you know (laughs)
and I didn't know what to do.
I was like, "Do I reach out to him?"
I mean, I don't think
he's listed or he's ...
but then his, two weeks
later, chief of staff called
and said, "You know you might
have heard Bill's a fan."
and I was like, "Yeah,
yeah. I heard that."
and they said, "If you're
free, we'd like to fly you up."
and I was looking at my
calendar's completely blank
and I said, "Yeah, I
think I could make it,
"make some time for Bill.
I gotta cut my nails
"but other than that, (laughs)
my schedule's flexible."
And I went up and I
really articulated this,
look, the time it was mainly,
the videos I was doing but I
was like, "Look, if we could get
"some resources." and I was
dreaming about a five-person team
and some office space.
That was the dream at that point.
We could build out the
software that I started doing
with my cousins so
students can get practice,
they can get feedback.
We just started building
a community on the site,
so the students can help each other.
We can build task ports for teachers
so that they could use
it to diagnose students
and leverage class time more effectively
and him and then later Google as well,
they were strong believers in that.
Nina: Great.
You talked a little bit
about talent and creativity
in your book and we talked a
little bit about this earlier on
but do you think, in
the advent of all this
not advent but since,
a couple of years ago,
there were books focused on talent.
Talent is Overrated,The
Talent Code, you name it
Sal: (laughs)
who I'm trying to foster
into a talented individual.
Do you think talent and
creativity are things
that can be in fact, you
know, taught to children
Sal: I don't think they're,
Sal: I'm not sure and frankly,
Nina: What's your thoughts?
I ...
My sense through both
(chuckles) observation
and just even seeing
what was happening there,
is it's not something that's taught
but it's something that can be untaught.
It's not something that it's not,
and it can be fostered
or it can be suppressed,
both talent and creativity.
And I actually think probably all,
I think everyone is born with creativity.
I mean there's not a
two-year-old on the planet,
who, if you introduce a
new object into the room,
will not walk up to that object
and manipulate it in every way,
taste it, feel it, see what they
can do with it, pour something,
There's not a two-year-old on the planet.
There's not a five-year-old.
Actually, most five-year-olds will still,
a new object in the room,
they will engage with it,
a new idea, they'll ask questions about it
but then something happens
where they're taught
to become more passive.
To some degree, they are in an environment
where questioning is not always cool.
They're so overwhelmed with work,
whether it's soccer practice or homework
that there's no time for them to
kind of just think about something.
The class is moving on.
They can't think about, "Wait,
why am I carrying the one?
"Why does that make sense? It
seems just like a formula to me."
They don't have time
for that type of stuff
and so, all of these
things, fall from this idea
of just breaking from this Prussian model,
breaking from this one
pace fits the lecture.
As soon as you take that out,
now, all of a sudden,
you can start saying,
"Hey, why we can't we let a student ..."
You know, right now, there's
a 16-year-old some place
in the country, who has just some insight,
like, "Maybe cancer can be addressed
in ... maybe this is what cancer is."
and too bad, the bell's gonna ring
or they have an AP test the next day
or they have an exam, he's like,
"Oh, I have too much work to do."
I have, I quote, an admissions
officer in the book talked
about she was interviewing
a bunch of people
who are coming to a very
elite college and said,
"What do you daydream
about?" and one student said,
"We don't daydream about anything
"because it doesn't help
us to get into college."
And it's tragic for that child
but it's tragic for society
because it's those daydreams
that eventually lead to actual,
I'll tell you know, Khan
Academy exist to a large degree
because my boss at the hedge
fund, a very nontraditional
for that field, had a
strong belief in life, work
in balance and so, I had time to
daydream about the Khan Academy.
I had time.
And my wife was a medical resident
so I felt bad sitting in bed
and watching TV and so, I was
able to think about this problem
and make resources and I think
anyone is capable of doing that.
We just have to give them the time
and the breathing room to do it.
Nina: Especially now, since
it appears, I don't know
if this was in your book or
I heard it from Tom Friedman.
I mean most of the jobs of
tomorrow are gonna be jobs
that are gonna be created,
not jobs that currently exist.
Sal: Yeah, exact- if you go, you
know, the Prussian model started
in the Industrial Revolution
and Industrial Revolution,
we needed probably more
educated people than we needed
in a kind of an agrarian civilization.
We needed people who
could read the directions
and have the discipline of the
assembly line and all of that
but there's also, there's
a certain passivity
that you also had to implicate.
In the farm, there's a certain
independence and freedom to it.
All of a sudden, in a
factory, you're doing this
over and over again and
one can debate whether
it was explicitly done
but there was an element of
instilling that passivity
in indoctrination so that
people could be good workers
but now, we're [in reality],
Before the pyramid was like this,
you needed a few knowledge workers
who are doing creative things
and then you needed a mass of labor.
Now, the pyramid's kind of inverted
where we need a lot of creative people.
In fact, all of the real
careers now are creative focused
and open ended and you need very few,
you need very little physical
labor and in that reality,
we're training people for this
while we need (laughs) the opposite.
Nina: Right and so since, we
are in the nation's capital,
do you have any advice for congress
or the president?
How can they best
help bring this vision to
life, understanding that?
Sal: Yeah, you know and this is,
it's an interesting
question because we do meet
with state officials and
federal officials and
even in other countries,
ministries of education,
and the one thing that I
don't want to happen is,
right now, it's been a very
grassroots grounds up thing.
People of word of mouth, Khan Academy,
people have been using it.
Parents have been telling parents.
Teachers have been telling
teachers and that's good
because that way, these are
people who wanna make it work
and they figured out and they tell us ways
to make it work better.
As soon as you make it top
down, I think it becomes,
no one likes it anymore.
And so, we want this
to be very grassroots.
What I really tell people is
just tell people about it.
Tell people, [tell them]
they have a free tutor.
Tell teachers that look,
there might be another model
that you probably will enjoy more.
There are ways to reach more students
and on top of that, and
I'm serious about this,
I think they should set an example.
It's become too, it's too
easy now in our society
for people to say, "Oh,
I'm not good at math."
And they'll say it out
loud like 6th grade math.
"Oh, I don't know. That's
math. I don't understand it."
No one will say, "Oh, I can't
read at a 6th grade level."
or, "I can barely write."
No one says that but people say,
you'll hear politicians say that.
You'll hear CEOs say that.
You'll hear people in the press say that
and I think that messaging should change
and frankly, the only
way that it could change,
is if they directly engage with it.
I mean it's shocking how many people
are engaged in education policy,
where they don't know the
subject matter themselves.
They're like, "Oh, I'm
not good at math but
"this is how we should
test math teachers."
It's like, that's crazy.
You yourself should engage in the
content or get a depth in the content
and that'll be a huge signal to society
and I think it also help inform policy
and I think the more they do that,
they'll realize that it's a
lot less about taught down,
a lot less about the controls.
The controls that they do, every
iteration of ed reforms is just
about more controls on
teachers and it might
de-risk some of the weaker players
but it also handicaps all the rest
and so it kind of gets into
this culture of everyone getting
to mediocre and what we really
need to do is go the other way.
Be much more grassroots.
What I point on this book,
that's an American thing
that we're a country that's
focused on creativity,
we're a country that's focused
on people taking ownership
over their lives but our school
system is a Prussian one.
One that's about passivity.
One that's about authority and
everything about this book is,
let's make our school
system more American.
Nina: Yeah, so any final thoughts?
If you were sitting with President
Obama at the White House,
aside from asking him to
use his bully pulpit more,
Sal: I'm somewhat serious about it.
Sal: I will ask him to ...
This is somewhat a different dimension
but we talked about this in the book.
I would ask him to make content for us
because I think what's happening
right now is the public discourse.
It's so disjointed in
these 30-second soundbites
that you can't have a chance to go deep
on either side of the aisle and right now,
the main adult learning
happens on the 24-hour news.
It's in this 30-second soundbites.
So, no one really understands the issues
and it just becomes very
emotionally, charged.
And this form factor, this
way, it's a chance for Obama
to really explain why he
makes the decisions he does
and maybe the opposition
to really explain why
and get to it and diagram it out
and even have a quiz afterwards
to make sure that people are retaining it.
It would kind of fill
in that gap in learning
that frankly, people are creative.
Some of our most popular videos
are about Credit Default Swaps
or the Healthcare Plan
or the Electoral College.
These are gaps in people's learning
and adults of any age want to learn that.
Nina: Yeah, well, it was a
pleasure reading this book.
It was nice meeting you.
Thanks for joining us.
Sal: Oh, it was a pleasure.